märz 2020 wieder grenzkontrollen
zwischen deutschland und frankreich
das finde ich tragisch dass die menschen
jetzt plötzlich sagen einer franzose der
infiziert nicht böse kilometerlange
staus richtung polen grenze dicht
[Musik]
militär am ostseestrand barrieren in den
grenzregionen bin enttäuscht von die
länder von also vom samen und fängt
deutschland es sind umstände die in
einem vereinten europa eigentlich nicht
tragbar sei keine grenzgänger keine
arbeit für die menschen ist es sehr hart
weil wenn jetzt nach hause fahren würden
heute nach der schicht müssen sie für 14
tage quarantäne und polnische quarantäne
ist nicht lustig bringt krone europa an
seiner belastungsgrenze bei gerhard
wagner ist die grenze vor der haustür
sie verläuft in der straßenmitte gerhard
wagner wohnt in leidringen deutschland
die nachbarn gegenüber in leder
frankreich ohne corona ist das praktisch
aber mitte märz war die grenze plötzlich
zu normalerweise würde ich das morgen
ist über croissants kaufen gehen das ein
katzensprung zum bäcker kreishaus
einkaufen und frische flüthmann wasser
nix alles geht es nicht schade
gertrud nachbarin gertrud hat
ausgangssperre
bei ihr ist risikogebiet in frankreich
gelten strengere regeln ein dorf zwei
länder und zwei ortsvorsteher einer
deutscher einer franzose corona hat
ihnen die grenze zurück gebracht sie
hatten sie längst verwischt als
neutrales als die neutrale strahlt wenn
mich die ganze stress ist neutral
die grenzposten still die stehen nur
wenn platzierte trude herr flieger
stehen
doch durch könne befugt ist das mit der
grenze hat deutschland alleine
entschieden in frankreich sorgte das für
unverständnis erzählen bertele minimal
und wolfgang schmidt die ortsvorsteher
sie berichten von der angespannten
stimmung bei ihnen beschweren sich die
grenzgänger die jetzt so lange umwege
fahren müssen die grenze
hauptgesprächsthema eben weil es sie
eigentlich nicht mehr gab der humus
rübergehen arbeiten sein dienst tun
die sommer bitte in ruhe lassen und
seine tätigkeit machen bat darum geht ja
aber das schlimmere finde ich es findet
ja auch eine stigmatisierung statt das
der franzose der ist kann der
gefährdeten ich mir wie mein kollege aus
deutschland das finde ich tragisch dass
die menschen jetzt plötzlich sagen der
franzose der infiziert mich böse die
polizeikontrollen bringen die grenze
zurück auf die straße aber offenbar auch
in die köpfe alte ressentiments sind
plötzlich wieder da ausgerechnet hier
der französische abgeordnete christoph
arendt und der bürgermeister von petrus
l in frankreich haben hunderte mails und
anrufe bekommen franzosen sollen in
deutschland beleidigt und sogar
angegriffen worden seien
krisen treffen auf der brücke die
deutschland von frankreich trennt
lokalpolitiker aus dem saarland und aus
lothringen versuchen die wogen zu
glätten
man hat französische kunden aus
deutschen geschäften verwiesen
französischen fabrikarbeitern in
deutschland wurde verboten sich draußen
ein sandwich zu kaufen solche sachen
problem
das alles führt zu sozialen problemen
ganz erreicht hier familien die auf
beiden seiten der grenze
wo man auch den leuten probleme die sind
sowieso schon traumatisiert durch das
virus durch die strengen ausgangssperren
das wird gerade alles nicht so geregelt
es ist der 15
märz der verkehr gerät ins stocken die
polnische regierung macht die grenze
dicht lkw stauen sich in richtung osten
kilometer lang die polnischen
grenzbeamten kontrollieren jedes
fahrzeug messen fieber jeder fahrer muss
fragebögen ausfüllen dauert der
abfertigung pro fahrzeug eine halbe
stunde
tausende europäer wollen oder müssen
zurück in ihre heimatländer abgewiesen
an der polnischen grenze gestrandet auf
der insel rügen fährhafen sassnitz
hunderte esten letten und litauer
drängen auf die fähre der reguläre
fährbetrieb wurde bereits eingestellt
estland hat eine sonder fähre
organisiert der botschafter ist vor ort
jedes land das regierung was muss muss
zusammenarbeiten wie heute und der
europäische lande das ist sehr sehr
wichtig und deutschland ist sehr gut
bereit ich glaube also ich hoffe es geht
es gut in dieser nacht werden 476 balten
mit der sonder fähre nach hause gebracht
weitere fähren werden in den kommenden
wochen eingesetzt am ende kehren rund
2000 menschen aus den baltischen ländern
auf dem weg über die ostsee zurück in
ihrer heimat am strand von usedom
patroullieren wieder bewaffnete
grenztruppen
die insel hat einen deutschen und einen
polnischen teil seit dem ende des kalten
krieges waren die grenzen europas offen
und kaum sichtbar
seit beginn der korona krise gibt es
wieder bilder wie diese gesperrt der
strand gesperrt der radweg kein
durchkommen
bei graz ist der grenzverkehr ebenfalls
fast zum erliegen gekommen
in normalen zeiten pendeln täglich 3000
polen nach vorpommern um hier zu
arbeiten
seit mitte märz ist damit schluss polen
hat die grenze auch für pendler dicht
gemacht
pendler wie machine szybalski oberarzt
an der pasewalker asklepios klinik ohne
mitarbeiter wie ihn wäre der betrieb
kaum aufrecht zu erhalten
ein drittel des medizinischen personals
in polen die hälfte von ihnen arbeitet
in der inneren medizin eine abteilung
die für corona patienten besonders
wichtig ist
also ich bin so genannte grenzpendler
ihr einen tag vater ich nach der arbeit
nach hause nach stettin da warne ich
auch mit meiner familie
was zurzeit seit gut drei wochen nicht
nicht mehr möglich ist
also faktisch ist ja die grenze
geschlossen
theoretisch dürfte ich nach hause musste
dann aber zwei wurden eine quarantäne
bleiben also es ist praktisch nicht
umsetzbar also hält der urologe hier in
der klinik die stellung
zwar gibt es bisher nur wenige corona
fälle im landkreis doch die klinik muss
sich vorbereiten auf schwierigere zeiten
die lage kann sich jeden tag ändern
wann dr wolski wieder nach hause kann
noch unklar
die situation für mich aber auch für
meine familie für meine frau die jetzt
alleine home office und homeschooling zu
hause macht und alleine zurechtkommen
muss selbstverständlich fehle ich zu
hause ich habe einen eindruck
kinderspielen es runter aber man zum
beispiel ist schon ab und zu weinerlich
und
das sieht man ihm an dass er mit der
situation probleme hat mit der trennung
und insgesamt mit der allgemeinen
unsicherheit deutschland hat sich
eingegrenzt mehrere hundert tausend
pendler müssen über nur wenige übergänge
pari laufer wohnt in frankreich und
fährt normalerweise hier über die grenze
zur arbeit nach deutschland
es macht eben im nachteil nach denke ich
dass wir nach durch den schengen-vertrag
die grenze in der vergangenheit geöffnet
hatten und jetzt sind wir im grünen
ungewollt in dem alten alten zustand
ari lauf war leitet ein
ausbildungszentrum des tüv im
saarländischen völklingen
im märz war er plötzlich ganz allein
normalerweise arbeiten hier über 100
menschen auch viele franzosen aus
lothringen dem corona risikogebiet sie
leben vom grenzübergreifenden
arbeitsmarkt zwangspause wegen des virus
uns fehlen schon die die französische
teilnehmerinnen teilnehmer in allen
gewerken die wir hier eben auch
aufzeigen konnten im eisenbahnbereich wo
die leute eben gebraucht werden oder in
der schweißtechnik und das merken wir
schon und mit sicherheit auch dann in
naher zukunft auch die unternehmen 2020
die deutsch französische freundschaft
hat wieder grenzen
albrecht schmidt wohnt neutrale straße
deutsche seite in laichingen und macht
gerade gartenarbeit statt autos zu bauen
er arbeitet bei ford in saarlouis aber
da ist kurzarbeit gleich zu anfang der
krise hatte sein betrieb den
französischen grenzgängern verboten und
zur arbeit zu kommen
viele unternehmen haben das so gemacht
wissen die bürgermeister das trägt nicht
zur guten stimmung bei ich bin
enttäuscht von die länder hoffen also
vom samen und wenn deutschland diese
grenze zu machen da bin ich enttäuscht
ich bin franzose haben in deutschland 47
jahre gearbeitet
ich bin europäer das ist es dort um geht
und man soll bisschen der europäische
gedanke spielen müssen und nicht den
nationalistischen und die populistischen
gegangen
klar es ist hier die nachbarregion ist
sehr betroffen dass weiß ich auch aber
letztlich wenn wir miteinander reden wir
ja wo ist der unterschied wenn ich jetzt
auf der seite lebe und auf der das sind
zehn meter auseinander
da bin ich plötzlich auch franzose und
genauso betroffen oder gefährdet
beim menü kruse dom werden kohlrouladen
gewickelt lebensmittelindustrie
mittelstand 36 menschen arbeiten hier
23 davon aus dem nachbarland polen nico
hat kurzarbeit angemeldet immerhin die
hälfte der polnischen mitarbeiter ist
zur zeit im betrieb seit die grenze
mitte märz für pendler geschlossen wurde
kommen sie wochenlang nicht nach hause
sind in ferienwohnungen untergebracht
geschäftsführer rolf engler versucht
trotz einschränkungen sondern betrieb
aufrecht zu erhalten
für die menschen ist es sehr hart weil
wenn jetzt nach hause fahren würden
heute nach der schicht müssen sie für 14
tage in quarantäne und polnische
quarantäne ist nicht lustig deswegen
haben die sich jetzt verpflichtet die
die hier habe für drei wochen erst mal
am stück hier zu bleiben
sie leben hier in ferienwohnungen sind
ganz ordentlich untergebracht und für
mich wäre das schon ein hartes brot
glaube ich auch wenn sie nicht mehr
jeden tag nach hause können ihren
deutschen arbeitgebern bleiben sie treu
auch jetzt in der krise
das ist eine beschissene situation egal
ob hier oder in polen gibt es so eine
ausgangssperre
natürlich vermisse ich meine familie
aber ich hoffe das dauert so zwei wochen
und wir sind wieder zu hause können
wieder ganz normal arbeiten und jeden
tag nach hause fahren und wohnen bei
unseren familien fürs krautwickel zahlt
die firma ihren mitarbeitern mindestlohn
mehr ist nicht drin
welche bedeutung haben die polnischen
mitarbeiter für ihren betrieb eine große
bedeutung eine lebenswichtige bedeutung
wir finden in deutschland nicht die
arbeitnehmer die wir brauchen wir finden
sie ins kino und das eine wunderbare
menschen die weder finden grenzübergang
linken zwischen polen und vorpommern am
24 april 200 demonstranten aus polen und
deutschland fordern lautstark ein ende
der schließung der grenze für pendler
mit abstand und mundschutz
lasst uns nach hause
lasst uns arbeiten die demonstration ist
zwar auf polnischer seite verboten
worden doch die grenzer schreiten nicht
ein
gerade was sie vor paar wochen noch
wirklich uns verbundene hartner das
leben ist ja beidseits der grenze
aufgebaut ganz viele besucher da die
familien normalerweise und haben da die
schule kita besuchen sie theater hier
haben sie was weiß ich
haus gebaut und die verbindungen sind
wirklich sehr verflacht
ihr protest hat erfolg zehn tage später
dürfen fast alle pendler wieder pendelt
demo auch den schengen ganz symbolisch
an europa denkmal stehen die
bürgermeister der grenz kommunen aus
frankreich deutschland und luxemburg mit
der grenze sagen sie
teilerfolg auch hier am vierten mai
haben das bundesinnenministerium und das
saarland beschlossen weitere übergänge
zu öffnen es mag erstaunen aber die
winzigen straßen sind im berufsverkehr
hauptverkehrsadern für pendl
viele unternehmen haben erste
lockerungen beschlossen bei ford in
saarlouis darf auf ein teil der
grenzgänger wieder zur arbeit
neue normalität mal so kontrolliert wird
noch immer den nach wie vor darf nur
nach deutschland wer einen triftigen
grund hat aber in
ja einfach nochmal normalität dass man
noch mal normal zur arbeit fahren kann
und dass alles wieder so wirklich hoch
her vielleicht mehr schön so was gab's
im leben nicht mehr geben
das grenzschließungen wieder stattfinden
also das schengen abkommen steht ja und
ich fand es ganz ganz schlimm wird es
ein gespann die krautwickel rinnen von
usedom sind erleichtert seit dem vierten
mai gilt für polnische pendler
sie dürfen wieder über die grenze müssen
den polen nicht mehr wie bisher zwei
wochen in quarantäne
die trennung von der familie ist vorbei
wir schaffen das wenn es arbeit gibt
dann arbeiten wir gerne erleichterung
auch bei der geschäftsleitung der
betrieb kann weitergehen
also die mitarbeiter könnten sie gar
nicht ersetzt nein nein
ihr könnt ihn laden zu machen doch noch
ist für das mittelständische unternehmen
die krise nicht vorbei
der absatz stockt die lieferketten sind
nicht mehr so zuverlässig wie vorher auf
staatliche hilfen wie sie viele andere
betriebe bekommen kann mit öko wohl
nicht hoffen wir als menü co haben das
problem dass wir in einer
sanierungsphase stecken deswegen an
keinerlei öffentliche darlehen oder
förderhilfen herankommen das ist schade
insofern hilft uns da der staat eher
wenig feierabend für den ober angst die
polnische regierung hat zwar die grenze
mittlerweile für viele polnische pendler
wieder geöffnet nicht jedoch für
medizinisches personal kommen sein
krankenhaus hat eine ferienwohnung
eingemietet für ihn und einen kollegen
seine frau und die beiden kinder acht
und zehn jahre alt leben nur 20
autominuten von hier entfernt zwei drei
wochen war er nicht zu hause aber ist
gut getroffen hier ja das ist wahr das
ist ein sehr schönes haus häuschen die
filme sehr wohl hier ein bisschen zu
hause auch oder besten die zu hause
obwohl zu hause ist es natürlich am
schönsten mit seinen vermietern ist er
sehr zufrieden die bringen eben auch mal
der karren vor bei vielen dank dafür
sagt ob der jet ski und das land gibt
einen zuschuss für solche
ferienwohnungen 65 euro pro tag
doch so ein leben fernab der familie
nicht eben leicht die erste woche mag
sogar schön sein da hat man endlich
seine ruhe und müssen erholung aber mit
der zeit wird man schon sehnsucht und
heimweh und mit der zeit wie die
situation immer unerträglicher dicht an
die schmerzgrenze bei harry laufer im
tif ausbildungszentrum ist seit dem 4
mai wieder betrieb auch die franzosen
sind wieder an bord
er hat ihnen grenzgänger bescheinigungen
ausgestellt
erst mal den regeln alltag ist das alles
noch nicht ganz aber die deutschen und
französischen kollegen arbeiten wieder
zusammen fast wie früher
wir müssen immer noch daran denken dass
hier zwischen saarland und richtung
protesten eine große freundschaft
herrscht verfassung auch denke ich mal
beide länder auch hochzuziehen durch das
werden die krankheit wieder vorbei ist
das sei es wieder in die reihe kommt im
ausland von lie dingen steht ein denkmal
genau auf der grenze ein fenster hier
kann man von deutschland nach frankreich
und von frankreich nach deutschland
gucken je nachdem auf welcher seite der
grenze man steht oder stehen da wolfgang
schmidt steht im moment nur in
deutschland und sorgt sich um europa auf
dem fenster ein gedicht im lokalen
dialekt den hier alle verstehen
er sagt europa ist ein dünnes eis und
wer hat er schon einmal fest driftet
also ich sag mal analog jetzt dieser
krise dann bricht europa ein das ist
eigentlich schon so vorweggenommen
dieser chor ohne kriege 35 jahre nach
der unterzeichnung des schengener
abkommens zeigt ein virus europa wo
seine grenzen sind